School choice has proven consistently popular among one very dependable constituency: parents.
And unpopular among another: unionized teachers.
The rapid spread of school choice over the past 20 years.
Has triggered an increasingly fierce union pushback setting up an inevitable clash.
Enter an insidious yet helpfully descriptive new term in policymaking:
Controlled Choice.
Yes, you parents still get to choose your desired schools
but public education bureaucrats get to control the final outcome
and lately from New York to San Francisco, Charlotte to Polk County
the only criteria that matters is not student performance but race.
'New York City schools got a little less segregated this week.'
my local city councilman in Brooklyn wrote at the beginning of this school year.
'The winner is everyone.'
Well, about that...
In 2007 the Supreme Court barred school districts from assigning students to schools based on race.
so instead they use income as the primary determinant
and characterized the resulting admissions changes as desegregation.
The goal is to have poorer kids homeless kids and english-language learners
spread out evenly among schools.
While crossing their fingers that parents won't bolt and that all schools will improve.
When this system was tried in my home district in Brooklyn It ended up being hellishly complicated.
The team that designed New York City's school picking algorithm literally won the Nobel Prize for economics
though, fun fact, one of those designers didn't like where the system placed his own kid
so he opted out and chose a charter and I don't blame him one bit.
The good news this year
is that kids from communities that had never even considered some of the high-performing schools
both applied to and were admitted in higher numbers.
School choice for the win!
But turns out parents don't much enjoy being controlled.
One size fits all schemes may look good on paper to progressives
but when applied to their own special snowflakes
suddenly lefty parents start sounding as skeptical of central planning as FA Hayek
or at least quietly eyeing the exits.
After more than a half decade of sustained increasing enrollment
my district sixth grade class shrunk by a whopping seven percent this year.
What happens in Brooklyn alas doesn't stay in Brooklyn.
The same policy process is underway in Queens and parents there are already revolting.
The New York City School Chancellor is not winning many new converts to these changes
with this habit of calling skeptical parents racist.
Meanwhile the city is considering a mandate that would require every traditional public school
have roughly the same racial ethnic and socio-economic makeup within ten years.
Good luck with that.
Parents of means can always take the expensive options of private school or physically moving to a new district.
But the main off ramp for the non-rich has been New York's extensive charter school system
now, just guess what kind of schools
New York politicians are placing an artificial cap on?
So how has controlled choice worked out there in the world?
The Cato Institute's David Armor looked at a half dozen controlled choice districts
and found that enrollment went down,
richer families fled and schools didn't even end up more integrated.
So a friendly reminder here from the People's Republic of Brooklyn:
controlled choice is an oxymoron.
top-down systems look bad from the bottom up,
choking off supply then browbeating demand is no way to run a service,
New York and other cities would be better off allowing more competitors to provide public education
and more choice to meet the idiosyncratic needs
of a challenging diverse and high achieving city.